bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale tout de
suite on passe au titre de cette
émission le premier magasin outlet des
galeries lafillette a vu le jour aux
clés sousbois une première mondiale qui
n'a pas manqué d'attirer les
consommateurs
l'usine Renault à Flin augmente sa
production et devrait embaucher pourtant
la direction reste encore fou sur les
chiffres et la nature des contrats
l'apprentissage en discussion le
gouvernement veut relancer la filière
dans lesines le nombre d'apprentis tend
à
diminuer zoom sur un métier d'égligence
celui de cuisinier une profession
toujours très
demandée les crêp c'est un fotcab cette
micro entreprise illustre le succès
d'une nouvelle forme de restauration la
restauration mobile
et puis nous parlerons de
l'apprentissage et des problèmes que
rencontre cette filière si impopulaire
en France nous retrouverons th Luro th
Luro bonjour vous êtes le président de
la capB des Yvelines la Confédération de
l'artisanat et des petites entreprises
du bâtiment nous reviendrons avec vous
sur les la situation actuelle et les
difficultés auxquelles les artisans sont
confrontés mais avant cela place aux
informations économique de la
semaine
samedi dernier le premier magasin outlet
des galer lafillette a ouvert une
première mondiale pour l'enseigne qui a
choisi le centre commercial one nation
Paris à cléousbois une nouveauté très
attendue par la clientèle du centre
commercial et aussi des alentours de
nombreux curieux sont venus jeter un œil
ou essayer de profiter des bonnes
affaires
- 30 50- 70 % sur des marques de luxe
une promesse faite aux consommateurs du
centre comm commercial one nation des
clés sous bois samedi ils étaient
nombreux à venir tout spécialement pour
découvrir le premier magasin à tête
galerie lafillette ça m'a l'air quand
même d'un très bon rapport qui a été
pris donc j'ai trouvé ça quand même
relativement bon marché j'en suis ravi
ça vaut le coup il y a les marques
effectivement beaucoup moins chers qu'au
galerie lafillette j'ai juste à un
chapeau voil bien
sûr et alors un prix intéressant 9 € au
lieu de 34,99 € donc voilà 800 m Carr
une ouverture mondiale dans les ivelines
le Paris pourrait sembler risqué pour la
grande enseigne pourtant les galeries
lafillette n'ont pas eu peur de ternir
leur image l'outl est tendance déjà très
développée à l'étranger il représente
aujourd'hui environ 3 % du parc
commercial français on va être le
premier grand magasin à ouvrir un outlet
ensuite il est important pour deux
raisons c'est que en terme stratégique
c'est un marché qui est en fort
développement évidemment tiré par la
conjoncture un peu difficile et cetera
le concept de l'outlet est un concept
qui fonctionne bien et donc là ça nous
permet d'écouler les fins de saison les
vieux stocks et cetera et donc de
renouveler encore plus l'offre dans nos
gros magasins une bonne opération dont
se félicite également le groupe cat
invest avec 140 millions d'euros
d'investissement la société a beaucoup
misé sur One nation ouvert il y a un an
le centre a accueilli 2 millions de
visiteurs si la direction se dit
satisfaite elle espère développer sa
dynamique économique avec ce partenariat
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait prévu
depuis 2 ans on a mis 2 ans à se mettre
d'accord sur un weekend on fait à peu
près 35000 clients ce qu'on attend donc
des galeries c'est une augmentation donc
du flux de 15 % clairement et surtout un
retour plus régulier des clients one
nation compte déjà 660 salariés et 11
personnes ont été embouchés dans le
cadre du lancement des Galeries
Lafayette d'autres emplois pourraient
être créés si l'objectif d'attirer 4
millions de visiteurs d'ici 2 ans est
atteint ce weekend Carlos Gon le patron
de Renault a annoncé que le groupe
allait embaucher dans les evelines
l'usine Flin devrait travailler à 50 %
pour Nissan le groupe avait déjà annoncé
en 2013 que le site s'occuperait de la
construction de 80000 nissad Micra par
an et cela pendant 3 ans selon le PDG le
site de Flin devrait produire 160000
voiture à partir de 2016 il a déclaré
sur Europe 1 je cite il y aura forcément
des embauches des propos plutôt
optimistes mais aucun chiffre précis n'a
été avancé ce qui ne rassure pas le
délégué CGT de l'usine Flin àikaya joint
par téléphone je vous propose de
l'écouter des embuches en intérim bah il
y en a par exemple à Flin aujourd'hui la
précarité explose on est à 1100
intérimaires sur un site qui compte 2200
CDI mais pour que les choses soient
crédibles nous on attend de voir
l'ouverture du GR en bouche ça c'est pas
encore fa l'opticien Chris group va
développer sa production de verre dans
les ivline la société va investir 13
millions d'euros sur 3 ans dans son site
de fabrication de basinville où sont
regroupées ces activités d'achat et de
production cette somme va servir à
augmenter les capacités des ateliers de
traitement afin d'accroître la
proportion la proportion de verre
l'objectif est aussi de poursuivre le
développement du télédétourage et de
passer de 7 à 10 millions d'articles
vendus par an 60000 60000 emplois pardon
devrai également être
créés vendredi le président François
Hollande réunit les partenaires les
partenaires pardon sociaux et régions
afin de trouver des solutions pour
l'apprentissage alors la filière ne va
pas bien 415000 apprentis ont été
recensés en 2014 alors que le
gouvernement vise un objectif de 500000
jeunes pour 2017 dans les Yvelines où
l'on compte entre 8000 et 10000 contrats
d'apprentissage cette tendance tend à se
confirmer si 8 jeunes sur 10 issus de
l'apprentissage trouvent un emploi tout
de suite en sortant de leur formation
les inscriptions en CFA dans notre
département baisse de 10 à 15 % selon
les métiers des images de William l et
Patrick de
dixmud son premier emploi Medy n'a pas
eu besoin de beaucoup le chercher la
société où il a appris son métier
d'artisan chauffagiste l'a pris en CDD
obtenir un job plutôt facile avec
l'apprentissage trouver une entreprise
en alternance est en revanche plus
compliqué les artisans sont soumis à de
nombreuses réglementations notamment
sécuritaires prendre un jeune s'avère
parfois plus une charge qu'une aide
réelle il faut trouver quoi parce qu'il
y en a qui sont déjà pris il y en a qui
prennent pas forcément
d'apprentis
parce que ça leur coûte
cher des choses des fois c'est assez
technique bah par exemple déjà utiliser
la disqueuse au début j'avais pas le
droit quoi vu que c'est dangereux puis
il faut bien prendre ses précautions
avant d'utiliser mettre ses lunettes ses
gants puis fa faire très attention
l'activité notamment celle des mineurs
est particulièrement encadrée par le
Code du travail ainsi un jeune couvreur
n'a pas le droit de monter sur une
échelle et un apprenti boulanger ne peut
travailler avant 6h du matin si des
dérogations sont possibles la lourdeur
administrative freine beaucoup
d'artisans comme l'explique Laurence
bourgeois elle a pourtant embauché ses
trois derniers apprentis s'il faut
respecter toutes les règles liées à
l'apprentissage effectivement il y a des
gens qui n'ont plus envie de travailler
avec avec les jeunes c'est trop
difficile la responsabilité est énorme
il faut faut bien apprendre à métier
faut bien savoir faire quelque chose
faut bien et pour se lancer dans la vie
bah il faut tester des choses des règles
lourdes à appliquer mais pas seulement
le contexte économique explique aussi
l'impopularité de l'apprentissage dans
les ivelines les effectifs des salariés
ont diminué de 22 et de 33 % au 1er et 2
trimestre 2014 dans les travaux publics
les entreprises ont moins de commande et
peu de visibilité à long terme pour
embaucher dans ce cas difficile de
s'engager pour 2 ans avec un apprenti on
développe de plus en plus de contrats
sur 1 an c'est-à-dire sur des deè années
donc on fait rentrer des jeunes en
contrat de 1 an de plus en plus je
trouve que la demande a exploser ces
deux dernières années l'an dernier déjà
c'était significatif et cette année
c'est énorme cet été seul 12 % des chefs
d'entreprise envisager d'employer des
apprentis en alternance dans ces
conditions attirer des jeunes en centre
de formation et d'apprentissage devient
un vrai problème il y a un an ces
établissements enregistraient déjà une
baisse de 3 % de leurs effectifs par
rapport à
2012 je vous disait tout à l'heure que
60000 emplois allaient être créés à
basinville en fait ce ne sera que 60
emplois qui vont être créés donc à
basinville ville par le groupe Chris je
vous propose de passer maintenant à
notre entretien de la
semaine notre entretien de la semaine
porte donc sur les difficultés liées à
l'apprentissage comme nous l'avons vu
dans le reportage précédent Cyril Hero
bonjour et merci d'être venu et d'être
avec nous sur sur notre plateau donc
vous êtes le président de la CAPEB je le
répète la capB des Yvelines c'est la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment vous
êtes vous-même artisan alors
premièrement est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer voilà les difficultés
auxquelles vous êtes confronté vous en
tant que professionnel du bâtiment et en
tant qu'artison face aux apprentis et à
l'apprentissage deux deux difficultés
bon la première conjoncturelle parce que
effectivement prendre un apprenti
aujourd'hui c'est un engagement sur 2
ans et comme le disait vot dans vre
votre
reportage on a un petit peu peur on n
pas la visibilité aussi longue distance
et puis ce qui a dit aussi des
difficultés administratives c'est c'est
quand même une une contrainte d'avoir un
jeune parce que ce sont des mineurs et
donc les les règles ne sont pas celles
qui s'applique à un travailleur
lambda
donc c'est difficile on peut pas leur
faire effectivement faire toutes les
tâches et pourtant notre rôle c'est de
les amener à l'autonomie donc s'ils
peuvent pas réaliser tout ce qui doit
être réalisé pour atteindre cette
autonomie il y a un moment on se sent un
petit peu et le jeune lui aussi se
rend compte de de ses
difficultés on évoquait dans le
reportage donc des des règles de
sécurité qui avait été instauré il y a
un an dans le cas du travail alors
quelles sont-elles je pense que dans le
bâtiment c'est quand même des une
profession qui est assez physique va y
en avoir beaucoup c'est vraiment
difficile pour vous dans ce cas de
prendre un apprenti et de lui imposer
ses règles comment ça se passe en fait
alors oui c'est
difficile ils nont quasiment pas
l'autorisation d'utiliser de machines
tournantes donc la une simple perceuse
que tout le monde a chez soi pour
accrocher un tableau ils n'ont pas le
droit d'utiliser les petits perforateurs
n'ont pas le droit de les utiliser euh
les disqueuses pour couper les tuyaux
dans notre cas ou d'autres matériaux
pour d'autres corps d'état ils n'ont pas
le droit d'utiliser euh on rappelait le
problème de de l'escabo hein c'est une
directive européenne qui s'applique à
tous les mineurs quels que soi les
métiers euh bah chez nous c'est une
complex cité quand même donc ça veut
dire que si on respecte les règles ce
sont des jeunes à qui voilà on qu'on
amènera pas vers cette fameuse autonomie
puisqu'ils seront obligés de demander à
leur tuteur en permanence de faire des
tâches pour eux qu'il n'auraient pas le
droit de
faire on fait quoi et ben je vais vous
le dire on outrepasse ce qui ce qui est
pas bien on se met en défaut hein par
rapport à la réglementation mais quand
on est maître d'apprentissage quand on
est tuteur le but il est il est de
transmettre il est que ce jeune au bout
de 2 ans voilà il il puisse commencer à
se débrouiller tout
seul si on peut pas lui apprendre les
bases du métier je vois plus l'intérêt
les les dérogations enfin il y a des
dérogations qui sont qui sont possibles
c'est très lourd il paraît que c'est
très très compliqué justement enfin
comment ça se passe à ce niveau-là pour
pouvoir faire enfin voilà pour un
boulanger que queun apprenti puisse pas
venir avant 6h du matin pour faire le
pain ça paraît comme improbable donc je
ne sais pas pour vous comment comment
vous organisez est-ce que ça vous prend
du temps de demander justement ces
dérogations bien sûr c'est bon c'est un
dossier à remplir évidemment comme on
sait si bien faire en France qui est qui
est lourd parce qu'il faut donner des
explications faut citer tout le
matériel vérifier les conformités du
matériel ça c'est c'est normal mais le
dossier est lourd ensuite c'est à
l'inspection du travail à directe de
décider si acccord la dérogation ou pas
euh moi je vais vous citer mon cas mon
avantdernier apprenti benah on m'a
refusé la dérogation donc je fait quoi
du jeune et pourquoi on vous a refusé
donc cette dérogation justement alors le
prétexte était que l'inspecteur ne
voulait pas lui porter la responsabilité
de signer cette dérogation donc vous
voyez le l'aberration dans laquelle on
se trouve c'est que moi on accepte de me
faire porter toute la responsabilité de
ce jeune que j'ai 3 semaines par mois
sur les chantiers et auquel je dois
faire très attention et on y fait très
attention et voilà et l'administration
me dit ah oui mais nous on veut pas
s'associer à cette responsabilité donc
bah débrouillez-vous sauf que c'est un
jeune voilà qui est mineur donc tant
qu'il a pas 18 ans si je respecte les
règles je ne le fais pas travailler
complètement son activité son métier
d'accord je comprends bien les
difficultés il paraît enfin il paraît
que que une prim de 1 € enfin ce n'est
pas encore très clair vous avez pas
vous-même des précisions une prime de
1000 € avait été enlevée elle est
maintenant réinstaurée elle sera donnée
donc aux artisans qui prennent un
apprenti on a l'impression que le
gouvernement quand même finance les
artisans qui souhaitent prendre des
apprentis pourquoi justement il ne il ne
peuvent pas finalement se permettre d'en
prendre et pourquoi les jeunes ont
finalement du mal à trouver une
entreprise pour les former alors la
prime elle est
anecdotique on considère que la la somme
ne ne ferapp pas que qu'un chef
d'entreprise prendra des apprentis ou
pas comme vous le disiez 1000 € c'est
par rapport au coût d'un apprenti ça
représente rien donc elle est plus dans
le sens d'une reconnaissance donc
l'annonce qui a été faite l'année
dernière de supprimer cette
prime a été un coup de tonner chez les
artisans qui se sont trouvés
déconsidérés et sont trouvés dans la
position de dire bah on sert à rien
puisque on peut même plus nous octroyer
cette prime on considère que ce qu'on
fait bah voilà on le fait c'est normal
et puis on a rien à à dire elle a été
remise en plus uniquement sur les
entreprise de moins de 11 salariés donc
tous les collègues qui ont plus n'y ont
pas droit euh et alors on attend demain
effectivement des des éclaircissements
quand
même vis-à-vis de ces primes parce que
c'est pas tout à fait bien clair mais
apparemment elle ne serait plus attribué
qu'aux entreprises qui embauchent un
apprenti pour la première fois ou qui
n'ont pas
embaucher d'apprenti depuis plus d'un an
donc c'est pareil ça va créer une
rupture justement al qu'est-ce que vous
attendez voilà des décision du
gouvernement qui montre que ce ne sont
pas que des paroles mais qu'il y a aussi
des actes et que
vraiment quand on nous parle de de voie
royale de l'apprentissage de voie
d'excellence de d'un de vraiment de
parcours vers l'emploi qu'on nous montre
que c'est vraiment ce qu'il pense et et
qui so avec nous dans dans ce parcours
nous on y est totalement engagé
l'apprentissage dans l'artisanin on en
vient presque tous donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui nous qui nous tient à
cœur mais on voudrait que l'État nous
montre que voilà c'est pas uniquement de
la communication c'est aussi réellement
un engagement qui sont derrière nous
avec nous et qui font ce qu'il faut pour
que l'image de l'apprentissage soit
valorisée très bien je vous propose de
passer tout de suite à la question de la
semaine c'est plus simple pour
s'intégrer plus rapidement dans le monde
du travail et ça permet d'avoir une
expérience donc voilà moi je pense que
ouais c'est l'avenir je pense que
effectivement c'est une voie qu'il faut
qu'il faut développer je pense pas que
il y ait de de forcément
systématiquement des débouchés par par
la filière scolaire et je pense que
l'apprentissage est une une alternative
c'est une bonne chose oui contre
l'apprentissage par contre faut que les
genses soient motivés aussi sans
formation
on peut rien faire enfin on peut pas
travailler ça donne l'expérience en même
temps que la formation pour l'insertion
professionnelle c'est c'est intéressant
on a plus de chance d'être pris
directement après nos études alors vous
tirez l'urau pensez-vous que
l'apprentissage est toujours une filière
d'avenir bien sûr vous le rappeliez tout
à l'heure 80 % des jeunes qui sortent de
l'apprentissage ont un travail à cette
sortie les 20 % qui ne l'ont pas tout de
suite le trouve dans les 3 ou 4 mois
donc on voit bien que c'est vraiment une
entrée vers le monde du travail vers
l'activité
incontournable très bien et bien je vous
remercie thry leuro d'être venu sur
notre plateau de nous parler ce sujet
très intéressant tout de suite passons
au chiffres de la
semaine cette semaine le chiffre de la
semaine concerne l'immobilier dans les
ivelines dans les ivelines pardon 3 1760
€ c'est le prix médian du mètre carré
sur l'ensemble du département un prix
qui continue de baisser si la baisse des
prix s'accélère les vente de volume
diminue également de - 20 à - 30 % selon
les communes à 50 ans en yeline les
agences ont moins vendu que l'année
dernière à la même période de moins en
moins de jeunes actifs et de primau
accédentss investissent dans la
communauté d'agglomération pourtant les
ilines restent le département le moins
cher de la petite
couronne je vous propose maintenant de
découvrir notre partie magazine avec le
zoom sur le métier de la
semaine notre zoom de la semaine est
consacré au métier de cuisinier la
restauration est le premier pôle de
recrutement national et le métier de
chef cuisinier est très recherché nous
avons rencontré José Morlot ancien élève
du grand chef étoilé Marc menud il est à
présent le chef le chef cuisinier du
restaurant La Fontaine à montinil
Bretonneux
c'est l'heure du premier service
autrement dit le rush en cuisine José
Morlot est concentré chef cuisinier
depuis ses 15 ans se passionné est
habitué au rythme soutenu de la
restauration et la journée commence tôt
avec la préparation des produits moi je
suis d'abord attaché à la cuisine
française c'est un métier on peut se
permettre de créer la formation de
cuisinier dure en moyenne 2 ans en CAP
ou école hôtelière avec la possibilité
de continuer en BTS si la plupart des
cuisiniers travaill en restaurant un
tiers de la profession soit près de
70000 personnes exercent dans
l'industrie l'agroalimentaire ou en tant
que traiteur le métier possède
différentes facettes et suscite nombreux
de vocations chez les jeunes tu suis le
bord du plat là et suis le bord papier
pr papier j'avais commencé par faire une
filière générale au LCÉE Descartes ça me
plaisait pas enfin donc du coup j'ai
préféré faire quelque chose que j'aimais
je quelque chose que je fais depuis que
je suis tout petit avec ma avec ma mère
du coup bah j'ai voulu devenir apprenti
pour faire un sa
en entrant sur le marché du travail un
apprenti perçoit en moyenne 1500 € net
le salaire varie selon l'employeur si
certains grands chefs sont millionnaires
tous les cuisiniers travaillent au
minimum 10 he par jour c'est des
horaires assez difficiles et puis les
contraintes familiale parce qu'il y a
plus de weekend il y a plus de jour
férier recruter un cuisinier est
compliqué en France plus de 35000 postes
sont à pourvoir chaque année et une
centaine pour le seul département des
ivelines pourtant la cuisine est à la
mode la récente médiatisation par
participe à améliorer l'image de la
profession et montrer son évolution le
cuisinier avont été mis dans l'ombre et
aujourd'hui il est mis en devant de
scène et c'est tant mieux pour le métier
parce que c'est quand même le créateur
de ces plats il faut avoir beaucoup de
connaissance il faut avoir un minimum
d'études il faut avoir et le but final
bah c'est créer sa propre entreprise
c'est ça si chaque année 20000 personnes
ouvrent ou reprennent un restaurant en
France peu de cuisiniers se lancent dans
l'aventure l'an dernier l'activité sur
ce créneau a reculé de 2 % on estime le
chiffre d'affaires de la restauration
traditionnelle à 30 milliards
d'euros et nous restons dans le domaine
de la cuisine avec une nouvelle forme de
restauration qui connaît un grand succès
c'est la restauration mobile alors de
nombreux entrepreneurs se lancent dans
l'aventure c'est le cas de Christophe
ebling un c'est un élan courtois qui a
quitté le monde du jardin pour se
tourner vers celui de la restauration à
presque 50 ans en avril dernier il a
lancé son entreprise un foot truck
appelé eau des crêpes une idée originale
qui a déjà fidéliser un bon nombre de
clients je vous propose de découvrir ce
sujet de Joren Torz et Claire Cambier je
vais aller chercher ma farine au moulin
de Versailles comme t tous les 15 jours
3 semaines Christophe ebling est devenu
un habitué des lieux lors de son jour de
congé il en profite pour refaire le
plein 30 kg de froman et 30 kg de bléoir
c'est un artisan du coin il est de
Versailles il fait Mme sa farine sa
farine de frent qui me convient bien il
y a un peu plus de 5 mois Christophe
s'est lancé dans une toute nouvelle
aventure et a créé ce qu'il revendique
être la plus petite crêperie du monde
une fois son véhicule rempli pas le
temps de traîner il a encore du pain sur
la planche nous le retrouvons le
lendemain à côté du Palais Omnisport
d'éancour le quinc gner s'est lancé dans
la street food un concept qui lui permet
de cuisiner et de vendre ses crêp à des
endroits différents selon les
emplacements on a une clientèle pareil
totalement différente et humainement
parlant c'est intéressant quoi avec on
lit pas amitié ENF on discute de choses
et d'autres il est midi la file
s'allonge et certains clients semblent
déjà adepte je viens juste pour vous un
autre jour et mais vous le dites à
personne on est d'accord nous ça nous
ég vu son aisance son enout TR presque
mais il y a plusieurs mois Christophe
travaillait dans un tout autre domaine
il était directeur de jardinerie
licencié il saisit alors le moment pour
se reconvertir il faut avoir la volonté
faut faut que ça soit le le bon moment
j'y pensais depuis un certain temps et
je crois que là là bon j'étais j'étais
mur pour me reconvertir euh pour être
mon propre patron sa belle famille est
en bretonne c'est sur le marché qu'il
repère quelques crépiers et que son idée
germe au fur et à mesure dès le mois de
septembre l'année dernière il se fait
aider par la Maison de l'Entreprise de
cquant an en Yveline tandis que la
Chambre des Métiers et de l'Artisanat
lui permet de travailler son business
plan 6 mois après le projet est validé
reste plus qu'à trouver les financements
il y avait toujours bon la maison
d'entreprise euh qui était derrière donc
ça c'est quand même un apport pour
rassurer un
banquier donc là-dessus j'ai pas eu trop
de trop de problèm seul ça aurait été
certainement beaucoup plus compliqué il
investit au final un quart de la somme
soit un peu plus de 20000 €. parmi les
investissements son fameux taxi anglais
que les clients remarquent et cette
petite cariole qu'il peut transporter
avec un concept différent de la plupart
des camions foot truck j'ai une
endouille camembert c'est génial ah bah
je vais tenter c'est surprenant mais je
vais ah vous allez voir c'est
Saint-Michel Saint-Malo au menu des
crêpes des galettes des produits frais
et des prix attractifs 1200 € par
semaine c'est à peu près le revenu que
Christophe doit dégager pour payer ses
crédits et commencer à être rentable
depuis le début du mois de septembre sa
clientèle est de plus en plus nombreuse
et régulière à tel point que ce jour-là
sa famille lui vient en renfort en 1h30
28 formules ont été vendues qu'on est
seul c'est c'est vrai que c'est parfois
un peu compliqué quoi il y a du monde
parce on faire les galettes donner les
boissons mettre dans les
boîtes encaisser quand on lui demande
s'il pense à terme engager une deuxième
personne le crépier préfère garder ses
projets secrets pour le moment faut
toujours avoir des des rêves des choses
diremon après comment on peut qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire après vous le saurez au
prochain
épisode on termine cette émission par
l'agenda de la semaine au programme de
rendez-vous la Cité des Métiers de
cquenttin en niveline organise un
atelier d'information gratuit destinée à
tous l'atelier comment construire un
projet professionnel réaliste et
réalisable il aura lieu le lundi 22
septembre de 14h30 à 16h30 à la Cité des
Métiers de sa-quanttin en Yveline à
trrappe une formation pour découvrir les
meilleurs outils du web les nouveaux
médias et leur impact sur l'économie est
mise en place par la Chambre des Métiers
et de l'Artisanat des Yvelines
l'objectif est d'apprendre comment
concevoir un site internet augmenter sa
visibilité et savoir utiliser les
réseaux sociaux dans le cadre
professionnel bien sûr elle dure en tout
14h et se déroule sur 2 jours le
vendredi 19 et le mardi 23 septembre
pensez à appeler afin de réserver vos
places je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivi je vous donne rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de filcho je vous souhaite une très
bonne
soirée